grosse foire merci d'être avec nous sur
rt france benyamin nétanyahou dénonce
des actes de violence et de harcèlement
de tous il pointe du doigt on vient
d'entendre le rôle joué par les médias
comment est-ce que vous analysez sa
défense sa réaction face aux
manifestations
ce n'est pas très bonne défense puisque
je pense que les deux ne sont pas du
tout en tout cas et donc je pense que la
violence est avant tout comment ça se
passe dans l'israël les piments n'est
pas tellement doux en général il compte
y le climat social au climat politique
les peuls heureusement le premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou aurait
poursuivi effectivement pour corruption
se trouvent des abus de confiance mais
il ya également deux autres chefs de
clans
vous êtes les autres plaintes majeur la
part des manifestants
la départ évidemment sa gestion
calamiteuse grenat en israël dans
beaucoup d'autres pays d'ailleurs
et puis aussi conséquences induites par
la mobilisation de clown à la crise
économique en israël on dit que le
chômage serait monté à plus de 5% dans
les derniers mois alors qu'il était
assez bas au début février
et donc je pense à toute une série pour
enregistrer comme à leur avis de
problème et puis il ya le risque aussi
toutes les violences et quand le fils se
met finalement à faire de la contre
violence a pour aider papa ça c'est pas
un bon signe même vient d'ordonner ce
dimanche aux offices de benyamin
netanyahu de cesser de harceler les
organisateurs des manifestations qui
réclament le départ le départ de son
père est ce que c'est anecdotique ou
révélateur d'une certaine façon de faire
moi je pense toucher à la fois
anecdotique est révélateur d'une façon
de chair parce que je trouve que les
arguments de monsieur dion va guère dans
l'unique ou est ce justifié
je crois que six arguments sur un peu
dérisoire est certain qu'il peut jaillir
de lannion quoi jeter des pierres sur la
raison d'un problème
ces jeunes atteignent ou dans ses
fonctions officielles est bien pire à
son idée alors le pouvoir dit le premier
ministre bon ça fait un moment qu'il est
effectivement là ce n'est pas la justice
et jusqu'à présent a réussi à s'en tirer
malgré encore une fois les trois chefs
d'accusation pas si pau corruption od
confiance et puis les deux aussi qu'il y
ait ce pasteur l'échec de la lutte
contre il ya une recrudescence de
l'épidémie en stage et volcy break parce
que le grenat griche il y avait
tellement large actuellement que son
impuissance aussi à régler la crise
économique et une crise sans doute
longue durée parce que finalement
l'économie israélienne n'est pas 600
salles et prospère qu'en apparence
ils prospèrent à condition que tu aimes
bien ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement
et puis il ya les mêmes dit sereine sur
lequel je pense que finalement ils sont
tous rangs notamment il ya un risque de
glissement vers la guerre civile
on voit comme une façon assez
symptomatique est symbolique des
artistes même le président de l'opac ben
spies sur la team s'est exprimé en
disant que ça pouvait devenir des deux
fictions imaginaire que nous est arrivé
que leurs débordements violents et
prononcé contre violence qu'ils puissent
avoir un mort d'un manifestant par un
excès de la police mais c'est rapide
c'est trop tard il gagne rapidement un
banc de touche du président de l'état du
chef de l'état israélien
il est vrai un rôle plus des chorales
aussi cette manifestante tout à l'heure
qui expliquait que la démocratie
israélienne était en danger ce que c'est
c'est votre sentiment aussi moi je pense
que c'est une fausse démocratie en
réalité parce que dans ce jeu des partis
mais n'oublions pas quand même que en
israël a atteint un problème fondamental
jeu dont parts on doit toujours leurs
amis leur apporter comme une partie des
dégâts
les citoyens israéliens qui ne sont pas
traités comme des citoyens avec 110
spectacles deuxième zone est donc au
fond ni les israéliens par les
palestiniens qui sont nationalité il
serait digne finalement personne
finalement sont tous traités comme des
citoyens deuxième tome est sujet à nous
répression cruelle au criminel est
globale et qui dure qui dure et qui tue
dans l'indifférence quasi totale je
pense qu'il fait un danger pour la vie
dont pâtissent à les éliminer de
l'intérêt n'était pas s'établir sur les
bases actuelles je partirai 10e et
philippe ça ne peut pas marcher comme ça
il ya toute une partie des citoyens et
des gens sous contrôle israélien
ils sont traités d'une façon cruelle
inhumaine injuste profondément alliant
des relais tout droit international et
du droit national
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions michel rambo ancien
ambassadeur de france